bonsoir nous sommes le 29 octobre
bienvenue pour une nouvelle édition du 7
8 lecture le journal de la rédaction
heureux de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition voici les principaux
titres que nous allons développer
Journée mondiale de l'AVC les accidents
vasculaires cérébraux qui font plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de victimes chaque
année rien qu'en France une personne est
touchée toutes les quatre minutes il est
donc important de détecter les symptômes
afin de mieux agir
devant la gronde les cotax qui doit
toucher les poids lourds dans les
prochains mois a été suspendus
aujourd'hui par le Premier ministre nous
entendrons les réactions d'un exploitant
agricole mais aussi des représentants
locaux d'Europe Écologie Les Verts qui
se battaient pour sa mise en oeuvre et
puis nous parlerons aussi politique avec
Catherine Perraudeau conseillère
municipal à Voisins-le-Bretonneux dans
l'opposition elle s'est engagée en
politique il y a plus de 30 ans ce ne
sont parcours dont il sera question
l'image du jour ce sont ces tableaux que
vous allez découvrir des tableaux
réalisés par un artiste congolais
léopolden glopadjevi ils sont exposés
durant une journée à l'hôpital André
Mignot au Chesnay une exposition
particulière et l'intervient ce 29
octobre Journée mondiale de l'AVC
l'accident vasculaire cérébral un AVC et
c'est d'ailleurs ce dont il a été
victime il a gardé d'importantes c'est
qu'elle Léopold de ne peut pas
s'exprimer correctement c'est donc le
médecin qui s'occupe de lui depuis 11
ans qui nous raconte son histoire c'est
au micro de Yolaine Torres
Léopold c'est un patient que je suis
depuis une dizaine d'années c'est un
monsieur d'origine togolaise qui était
peintre et qui a présenté il y a un peu
plus de 10 ans un hématome intracérébral
lié à une hypertension artérielle très
sévère mal contrôlé c'était mattum a été
pris en charge dans l'hôpital de Lomé
avec les moyens du bord et il en a gardé
des séquelles importantes avec une
hémiplégie
massive et des troubles du langage ce
qu'on appelle une aphasie
Léopold était peintre et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'il est toujours
peintre il a changé il était droitier
maintenant il peint avec la main gauche
et la qualité artistique est toujours la
même et ses œuvres sont toujours aussi
émouvantes et belles
ce mardi 29 octobre c'est donc la
Journée mondiale des accidents
vasculaires cérébraux en France les AVC
sont responsables de deux fois plus de
morts que les accidents de la
circulation c'est la troisième cause de
mortalité en France une journée
d'information et de prévention était
proposé au centre hospitalier Mignot au
Chesnay Catherine sulato Jonathan
villemann
Marie a fait un AVC à laver 54 ans
c'était pendant la nuit de son AVC elle
a perdu le langage qu'elle a duré à
prendre pour elle les causes sont
connues la pilule la pilule troisième
génération voilà et le tabac évidemment
parce que je fumais beaucoup je
travaillais beaucoup aussi j'avais trois
j'ai trois enfants à Marie voilà mais
donc le stress voilà mais c'est surtout
la pilule quand on a fait un AVC faut
travailler travailler travailler
travailler tous les jours tous les jours
je fais pendant des années
tous les jours j'étais à Paris pour
j'avais une orthophoniste qui est
formidable qui est toujours là et j'ai
encore des séances d'orthophonie une
fois par semaine en France les accidents
vasculaires cérébraux sont la troisième
cause de mortalité dans 80% des cas
c'est une artère qui se bouche dans les
20 autres %, c'est dû à une hémorragie
des raisons expliquent les AVC la
première de toutes l'hypertension puis
viennent le cholestérol le tabac et
l'alcool
je vais essayer de touche pas que les
seniors 15% des moins de 50 ans peuvent
être concernés les symptômes sont mal
connus alors c'est très important que
les gens soient conscients qu'un AVC ça
survient brutalement et les symptômes
les plus importants sont la déviation de
la bouche la difficulté pour parler ou
la faiblesse d'anémie corps un émiscor
soit la jambe soit le bras on peut aussi
avoir c'est moins fréquent mais ça peut
aussi arriver la baisse brutale de la
vue d'un œil ces symptômes sont des
symptômes extrêmement importants à
repérer et ensuite il est très important
que la personne appelle le 15 et en
appelant le 15 elle sera immédiatement
acheminé vers une unité neurovasculaire
comme ici à Versailles ces symptômes
c'est important le délai de les dépister
tôt parce qu'on a actuellement un
traitement un traitement parois
intraveineuse qu'on peut administrer
dans les 4h30 dans un tiers des cas le
traitement permet de rétablir la
circulation de façon normale il est donc
très important d'intervenir le plus tôt
possible 10 à 15% des patients décèdent
dans la phase aiguë et les trois quarts
vont garder des séquelles soit motrice
soit intellectuelles le samedi 14
décembre un concert aura lieu à 15
heures à Versailles les fonds collectés
seront reversés au profit de la
recherche une antenne yvinoise de France
AVC vient d'ouvrir
et dans le cadre de cette journée le
message est clair il faut apprendre à
détecter les signes annonciateur d'un
AVC afin d'intervenir au plus vite
connaissez-vous les symptômes de l'AVC
c'est notre question du jour et voici
vos réponses on a du mal à parler
on a des picotements dans les mains non
pas vraiment non je suis désolé
quand on serait de travers quand il y a
un qui marche quand on est pas l'autre
quand on bafouille quand on a les
problèmes au MAAF à côté une asymétrie
de la motricité en fait douleur
évidemment au coeur je pense on a du mal
à parler
je crois qu'on a on a des modes de tête
les symptômes de
rictus facial etc d'avoir des
picotements dans la main
ou demander à quelqu'un de sourire avoir
un patient qui s'en va de côté qu'est-ce
que j'ai retenu d'autre je ne sais plus
ah oui essayez de faire marcher
quelqu'un tout droit et voir si
l'équilibre
suspension mais pas suppression
Jean-Marc Ayrault à reculer aujourd'hui
sur le dossier de l'écotax mais il ne
veut pas enterrer ce nouvel impôt il
annonce avoir besoin de temps pour mener
un dialogue au niveau national mais
aussi régional c'est en Bretagne
d'ailleurs que la contestation a été
elle la plus forte rappelons que
l'écotax est un dispositif visant à
taxer la circulation des poids lourds
afin de financer les infrastructures
ferroviaires et fluviales il a été
initié sous la présidence de Nicolas
Sarkozy et devait rapporter un milliard
d'euros par an à l'état Yolaine Torres
fais le point sur les différentes
réactions dans le département
ces portiques de contrôle sont devenues
le symbole à abattre pour les opposants
à l'écotaxe cet axe d'environ 13
centimes par km en moyenne
augmenteraient de plus de 4% le prix du
transport routier pour les poids lourds
déjà maintes fois reporter sous une
application était prévue le 1er janvier
2014 coup de théâtre ce matin le Premier
ministre Jean-Marc Ayrault annonce sa
suspension dans tout le pays une
décision qui ne satisfait qu'à moitié
Jean-Claude Guennec propriétaire d'une
exploitation agricole lui demande la
suppression totale de cette taxe les
motifs évoqués trop d'impôts trop de
charges la seule solution c'est purement
d'arrêter notre métier alors tout le
monde dit manger des produits de
proximité et on dit toute taxe encore et
on nous dit oui les autres produits vont
être taxés avec l'écotaxe on sait que
par exemple des produits espagnols vont
prendre l'autoroute ils vont arriver
jusqu'à Saint-Arnoult et ils vont pas du
tout être taxés donc nous on va passer
sous 4 ou 5 portiques sur le produit
donc là il y a pas d'égalité au niveau
de la taxe pour une entreprise
au niveau particulièrement arboriculteur
maréchal ou horticulture ces textes-là
peut représenter entre 2000 euros
jusqu'à 30 000 euros par entreprise donc
nous on va pas pouvoir y percuter ça on
n'est pas des transporteurs donc on peut
pas rajouter ça en facturant les grandes
surfaces on peut dire monsieur vous
rajoutez ça en bas de votre lecture du
côté de repécologie les Verts on est
pour cet écotaxe elle permettrait
notamment de favoriser d'autres modes de
transport moins polluants comme le
ferait tout le transport fluvial du coup
l'annonce de sa suspension n'est pas vue
d'un bon œil
de ne pas l'appliquer si j'ai bien
compris sur la France entière ça c'est
tout à fait regrettable la Bretagne des
aménagements avait déjà été pris en
compte sur le fait que ce qu'une région
périphérique donc le taux n'était pas le
même que dans le reste de la France un
certain nombre de produits en été
exonérés c'était déjà pris en compte
c'est quand même un très mauvais signe
pour la transition écologique d'après
les chiffres du gouvernement l'écotaxe
devrait rapporter plus d'un milliard
d'euros par an
l'invité de ce 29 octobre de ce journal
c'est Catherine perraudo bonsoir vous
êtes conseiller en municipal
d'opposition à Voisins-le-Bretonneux 34
ans de mandat local vous venez de
recevoir l'ordre national du Mérite pour
l'ensemble de cette carrière qui
continue ou c'est toujours conseillère
municipal et on va en parler vous serez
d'ailleurs candidate sur la liste
d'Alexandra Rosetti sans doute peut-être
je ne sais pas c'est elle qui décidera
alors on verra ça encore d'entrée de
l'entretien tout d'abord on revient sur
cette carrière de plus de 30 ans lorsque
vous avez débuté lorsque vous vous êtes
engagé en politique vous aviez derrière
la tête de rester aussi longtemps ah non
j'avais absolument aucune idée de de
cela cette de cette longévité je vais
surtout beaucoup de surprises et
beaucoup de questions en tête parce que
je ne connaissais absolument rien la
fonction donc mon premier souci c'était
d'apprendre et puis après les choses se
sont enchaînées les années 179 premier
élection municipale dites complémentaire
après le décès du maire il fallait
revoter vous dites on est venu vous
chercher
oui oui j'étais membre d'une association
de parents d'élèves
moitié du plan de l'église à voisins qui
se déguste enfin qui était en pleine
construction une école qui démarrait et
puis au moment du décès du maire on est
venu me demander si je voulais bien
devenir conseiller municipal ah si
j'hésitais parce que je ne connaissais
absolument rien à la fonction et mon
premier réflexe a été de me dire je
saurai jamais
et puis
un petit peu de curiosité un petit peu
de courage aussi et puis une volonté
d'un engagement citoyen je me suis dit
après tout pourquoi pas pourquoi pas moi
la ville comptait environ 3000 habitants
aujourd'hui c'est environ 12000 11000 et
quelques tout a été à faire au cours de
vos différents mandats et c'est ça qui
était passionnant parce que
quand on est arrivé il y avait en gros
il y avait Champfleury et le centre
village enfin l'ancien village et donc
tous les quartiers nouveau se sont mis
en place avec les logements et puis
aussi avec les équipements et comme je
m'occupais des affaires scolaires
c'était surtout à ce moment-là mettre en
route les les centres de loisirs
associés et tous les services municipaux
qui vont avec donc c'était beaucoup de
travail c'était beaucoup d'engagements
avec en plus des moyens qui étaient
assez artisanaux à l'époque pas beaucoup
d'agents pas beaucoup de structures
supports exactement moi je me rappelle
monsieur quand j'ai été élu il y avait
exactement trois agents administratifs
donc plus le secrétaire de mairie on
disait pas directeur des services vous
voyez c'était extrêmement extrêmement
restreint et il est vrai qu'à ce
moment-là les élus mettaient vraiment
les mains la main à la pâte elle les
mains dans le cambouis je me souviens
d'avoir par exemple été compter les
maisons un soir de commission scolaire
compter les maisons en chantier pour en
déduire le nombre d'élèves qu'on était
susceptibles de de recevoir et donc des
postes à demander voilà c'était des
choses c'était très très accusés
un petit peu le fil de votre carrière
1979 donc vous entrez dans cette
majorité de droite vous êtes au repère
mais elle était c'était pas du tout
influencé par les parties le l'ancien
maire je serai incapable de vous dire le
parti politique de l'ancien maire enfin
de Maurice Laure qui était décédant en
79 René Van Damme et lui met en 79 et
n'était pas de gauche ça c'est clair
mais elle avait pas d'étiquettes et
c'est toujours refusé avoir quelques
cartes de partis politiques que ce soit
différent par rapport aujourd'hui à
l'époque au niveau des municipales les
partis politiques s'intéressaient peu
aux partis politiques s'intéressaient
pas beaucoup à nous nous on
s'intéressait pas beaucoup parti
politique donc chacun faisait son
travail dans son coin et c'était et
c'était bien c'était c'était vraiment le
souci du local du terrain du bien-être
des habitants qui arrivaient alors tout
c'était aussi assez intéressant parce
que les habitants qui arrivaient avaient
tous leur passé moi où j'étais alors
c'était soit la province soit la
couronne parisienne donc ils arrivent
avec leurs expériences qu'ils avaient
connu et ils attendaient qu'on leur
procure la même chose et au plus vite
vous avez adhéré par la suite au RP
après oui j'ai été
après vous avez quitté l'UMP pourquoi ne
pas avoir ne pas être resté au sein de
ces différentes formations politiques et
bien parce que le
MP quel je vote toujours et pour lequel
j'ai toujours beaucoup de sympathie
à des des attitudes au moment des
élections municipales que je
qualifierais de déroutante voilà pas
pour ne pas dire plus alors c'est pour
ça que je trouve que c'est pas la
priorité je suis
UMP de coeur local doit se différencier
des différents formations politiques je
trouve que les les batailles de partis
politiques à l'échelle des municipales
ne présente pas un grand intérêt alors
je parle pas de grandes communes comme
Paris ou Lyon ou Marseille évidemment
mais une commune de 11000 habitants
comme voisins peu importe la couleur
politique oui du moment qu'on a des gens
de bonne volonté alors bien entendu je
je n'irai pas sur une liste notoirement
de gauche mais à partir du moment où on
a une liste de droits de centres avec
des gens de bonne volonté qui ont des
idées et qui veulent faire avancer les
choses moi je suis ouverte à toutes ces
opinions je reviens au fil de votre
carrière 79 vous débutez donc en
politique 83 municipales vont rester
donc rien à faire avec une nouvelle
victoire adjointe aux affaires scolaires
ensuite entre 89 95 premier adjointe oui
95 en revanche c'est la défaite Alexis
Viette qui l'emporte c'était son premier
mandat il est toujours le maire en place
comment vous avez vécu ce moment où il a
fallu siéger dans l'opposition c'est
bien différent alors je crois après coup
avec le recul on apprend beaucoup de la
défaite et passer 6 ans dans
l'opposition c'est à la fois frustrant
parce que surtout quand on a été en
charge comme premier adjoint beaucoup de
dossiers et qu'on a vraiment eu le
sentiment de faire avancer les choses
c'est un peu frustrant même très
frustrant en revanche on apprend
beaucoup de choses
dans les comportements dans les dans les
manières de traiter les personnes et je
trouve que c'est un excellent
apprentissage de la démocratie
perfectionnement dans l'exercice de la
démocratie pour autant en 2001 vous vous
dites j'arrête oui parce que parce que
vous ne souhaitez pas vous représenter
parce qu'on n'avait pas le sentiment
avec avec mes amis de l'époque de
pouvoir
apporter quelque chose de vraiment
différent on avait fait notre temps donc
on a on avait décidé de ne pas se prêt
de ne pas monter de liste de nos
soutenir aucune liste donc on ne
soutenait pas la liste ni du maire
sortant
absolument mais ça a été une retraite de
courte durée parce que suivant même pas
là dessus
sont organisées on peut peut-être
rappeler un petit peu la situation
comme on avait décidé de pas se
représenter on était vraiment très en
retrait on n'a pas participé à la
campagne de 2001 Alexis bieette et enfin
la liste d'Alexis est élue en 2001 assez
logiquement sauf que au moment des lire
le maire il y a un coup de un coup de
théâtre ce n'est pas lexibiet qui était
lui-même mais quelqu'un de sa liste donc
évidemment c'est la stupeur
alors nous on n'a pas eu les détails de
de cette affaire là puisqu'on était pas
on n'était pas dans le dans le saint du
Saint des saints mais c'est évidemment
un coup faire absolument extraordinaire
à la fois avoisin mais même à l'échelle
nationale parce que c'est un événement
qui n'est pas assez rare que le tête de
la tête de liste ne sorte absolument
donc
ce que de tiers du Conseil municipaux
ont démissionné c'est-à-dire qu'à la
fois la liste socialiste et les
conseillers municipaux la liste
socialistes ont aussi décidé de
démissionner parce que ce qu'ils étaient
passés ne leur convenait pas et trouver
ça absolument inacceptable donc les
élections étaient invalidées
oui parce que je lui ai dit d'ailleurs
aussitôt après le putsch entre
guillemets autant je pouvais ne pas
avoir être en désaccord sur certains
points de sa politique ce qui s'était
passé au moment de semaine de sa non
élection me paraissait absolument
inacceptable et donc on a décidé de
faire front avec lui dans cette dans
cette difficulté et donc nous avons fait
liste commune pour les élections de de
mai 2001 alors je voudrais pas perdre
non les téléspectateurs qui nous suivent
et qui sont peut-être pas familiers tous
avec la vie politique sur voisin le
Bretonneux mais pour autant en 2008 un
nouveau scrutin c'est le jeu
démocratique et vous ne soutenez pas
cette fois-ci alexibiette mais non parce
que vous rejoignez
des dissidents qui étaient largement
majoritaires puisque la plupart des
mères adjoints de l'époque ont décidé de
faire liste commune avec Joël le nom
on était on était dans les adjoints on
était largement majoritaires il y a un
seul adjoint qui est qui est resté
proche de
d'Alexis donc on a monté de le rejoindre
à un moment pourquoi décider de le
quitter à un autre et bien parce que
l'expérience du mandat de 2001 à 2008 a
été aussi porteur de leçons
il s'est passé des choses sur lesquelles
je ne reviens pas parce qu'elles ont été
c'était des bonnes choses pour voisins
mais il y a un certain nombre de
d'éléments qui nous ont paru absolument
à combattre et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
a décidé de faire cette liste avec avec
Joël lenand d'autant que le maire avait
annoncé qu'il ne se représentait pas et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que ça avait
représentait vous avez changé aussi
est-ce que vous auriez aimé faire une
carrière politique dans une ville
peut-être plus calme plus calme
où est-ce que ça fait partie du jeu
politique c'est-à-dire que vous savez on
n'a pas d'idée à l'avance de ce que de
ce que vont être les vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir réussi à faire avancer
des dossiers d'avoir travaillé malgré ce
climat parfois les deux mandats où
j'étais premier adjoint il y a un
particulier le dernier il y a un certain
nombre de dossiers cruciaux qui ont été
qui ont été qui ont été menées quand je
suis en 2001 ils étaient le moment de la
mise en place des 35 heures dans la pour
le pour le personnel donc c'était un
gros travail il a fallu le mettre en
place
en concertation avec les avec les
différents partenaires il y a eu le
label calviville c'est-à-dire le label
de certification qualité pour les
services d'accueil de la de la mairie et
d'autres d'autres dossiers et puis
surtout peut-être ce mandat d'entre 2001
et 2008 il a été marqué par davantage
d'intercommunalité là on sentait les le
début d'une intercommunalité beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus présente j'étais
délégué communalité donc j'avais à la
fois les relations avec avec la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin
le parc naturel des lattes vallées de
Chevreuse donc vraiment des partenaires
extérieurs à voisins et c'était aussi
des dossiers qui étaient très
intéressants à mener si vous a permis de
vous épanouir sur le plan politique
absolument de questions que j'aurais
souhaité vous poser il nous reste
finalement assez peu de temps si vous
pouviez faire des réponses très très
courtes vous serez candidats tout le
monde 2014 et bien écoutez je ne peux
pas vous le dire parce que pour le pour
l'instant nous sommes rapprochés
d'Alexandra Rosetti qui annoncé sa
candidature
se répète de quitter Alexis moi je note
je note que ça fait trois fois que le
premier adjoint d'Alexis
se sépare de lui à la fin du mandat bon
peut-être y a-t-il de cela des
conclusions attirer donc pour la
soutenez et vous disiez lorsqu'on a
discuté un peu pour préparer cet
entretien que c'était important aussi
parce que c'est une femme oui alors moi
c'est une c'est une aventure qui me qui
me plaît beaucoup parce que vous auriez
vous aurez noté comme moi que
Saint-Quentin n'a jamais eu de mer femme
sans être une féministe chevronnée je
pense que le féminisme il se vit sur le
terrain et j'aimerais assez bien vivre
cette aventure d'une d'une femme mère à
Voisins après 30 ans de carrière en
politique
vous n'y pensez pas bon écoutez elle
viendra en son temps merci Catherine
perodeau conseillère municipal de
position voisin Bretonneux engagée
depuis 34 ans en politique dans cette
commune merci si vous suivez la
politique n'oubliez pas ce mardi je vous
retrouverai aussi à 18h30 19h30 et 23h
pour une nouvelle édition de municipales
2014 il sera question de candidature à
Saint-Cyr-l'École Léa Élancourt
notamment sport France-Angleterre une
vieille rivalité dans ce domaine qui se
retrouve jusque dans les catégories les
plus jeunes les équipes de moins de 13
ans et de moins de 15 ans d'Élancourt
ont affronter celle de Birmingham et à
l'arrivée de match nul les joueurs sont
pris ce match très au sérieux vous allez
le voir avec Anthony Rey chez Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude
je vous parle d'un temps d'un temps du
football que les moins de 13 ans ne
peuvent pas connaître pourtant la
rivalité France-Angleterre sur le
rectangle vert semble se transmettre à
chaque génération c'est un match amical
mais quand même c'est la première fois
que je suis un grand terrain en fait et
ouais c'est une expérience bien à vivre
c'est un match donc bien sûr il y a pas
il y a pas de danger principal mais
c'est toujours plaisant pour les garçons
de repartir avec une victoire et
continuer dans la lancée depuis le début
de championnat dans le cadre d'un
partenariat avec le Paris Saint-Germain
le club de Birmingham fait étape dans
les Yvelines pour se frotter aux jeunes
footballeurs d'Élancourt depuis
plusieurs semaines les Anglais ont même
augmenté la cadence de leurs
entraînements en vue de la rencontre
quel que soit le niveau un franc
Angleterre cela ne se rate pas autrement
c'est un match important c'est une
grande opportunité pour mes jeunes de
venir se frotter au niveau international
on se prépare à cette rencontre depuis
près de huit mois
les jeunes élancourtois relèvent le défi
physique anglais résiste bien à leur
agressivité dans les duels mais à
l'arrivée français Angleterre ne se
départage pas de match nuls un but
partout chez les U13 et de deux pour les
U15
en parallèle d'un spectacle musical de
hip-hop qui se monte en ce moment au
scarabée à La Verrière des initiations
au beatbox sont organisées à la Maison
des Jeunes découvertes à présent de
cette univers musical qui reproduit le
son des instruments avec la bouche mais
aussi le nez avec Olivier Maniscalco et
l'autre dis-moi peut-être vont-ils nous
faire une petite démonstration
une petite démonstration pour marquer
les esprits ça y est l'initiation human
beatbox peut enfin commencer à la Maison
des jeunes de la verrière mouvement issu
du hip-hop est né dans les années 70 à
New York le beatbox consiste à imiter
vocalement des instruments de musique
très technique il est aussi difficile à
enseigner il faut donc trouver des
méthodes pour aider la quinzaine
d'enfants présents ce lundi à jouer les
boîtes à rythme il faut les prendre en
main pas trop beaucoup de personnes avec
vraiment avec un monde restreint et
qu'on puisse bien leur apprendre avec
des mots parce que le beatbox ça
s'apprend avec des mots ça s'apprend pas
aussi que avec des des fois leur
expliquer comment on fait avec une
technique Comment comment apprendre en
fait porte à capuche je vous expliquer à
la ça fait pour ta capuche Taka porter
ta capuche et quand on ensuite on a bien
reçu le truc ça fait
des instruments comme j'aime beaucoup la
musique bah j'aime bien le faire du
beatbox
un spectacle melon hip-hop big box
musique et vidéo est actuellement en
préparation dans la salle du scarabée le
metteur en scène un interview là
originaire de La Verrière va permettre
de prolonger les initiations à la
discipline pour les jeunes il prêtera
les beatboxeurs de sa production et ce
jusqu'au 24 janvier date de sa première
représentation
halloween approche nous faisons le point
ce soir sur le marché des déguisements
avec Claire Cambier
des crânes des masques de monstres des
chapeaux de sorcières les clients de ce
magasin de Maurepas font le plein pour
les fêtes d'Halloween surtout de la
décoile d'araignée cette maman organise
une soirée pour sa fille et ses amis
mais les produits sont aussi destinés au
plus grand ces deux jeunes filles par
exemple compte bien faire la fête aussi
nous on sort on fait entre amis et on va
dans un pub tous dans un pub et ouais le
pub aussi est décoré donc voilà ces
soirées plus à thème mais cette
célébration importée des États-Unis
a-t-elle réellement du succès et
est-elle source de rentrer financière
pour les commerçants les premières
années Halloween il y avait une forte
montée en puissance en charge je sais
pas il y a à peu près 7-8 ans et puis
c'était retombé vraiment très très de
façon très rapide et puis depuis quatre
cinq ans halloween c'est
c'est une fête au delà du côté culturel
américain je pense que les Français se
sont appropriés cette fête comme un
moment de défoulement quoi
et donc ouais j'ai bonne espoir que ça
continue cette enseigne réalise 5 à 10%
de son chiffre d'affaires pendant ces
fêtes trois personnes sont d'ailleurs
venues en renfort dans ce magasin
Halloween tombant la veille d'un
week-end de trois jours le bilan devrait
être bon une période non négligeable
même si les clients venus aujourd'hui
compter aussi sur la débrouille là on
achète parce qu'on a besoin sinon on
essaye avec le maquillage à la maison
avec les vêtements qu'on a déjà on
essaie de voir un petit peu si on a il
nous manque des accessoires oui on vient
les acheter sinon dès qu'on a on fait
avec les moyens du bord dès la semaine
prochaine les articles d'Halloween
seront remplacés par ceux de Noël et
Nouvel An les ventes prendront alors une
toute autre ampleur
fin de ce journal je vous retrouve
demain mercredi excellente soirée sur
téléfils